دا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرحبًا بالجميع، اسمي أنا هنا
للتحدث عن شيء ما يجعلني
سعيدًا حقًا لعبتي، إنهم مثل أفضل
أصدقائي وأريد أن أخبركم لماذا
هم مميزون جدًا بالنسبة لي، هذه هي
لعبتي المفضلة
سباركي يوني هو حفلة ناعمة بالإضافة إلى
وحيد القرن أحب أن أعانقها لأنها
تجعلني أشعر بالأمان والراحة خاصة
عندما يحين وقت النوم، تساعدني سباركي على
الاسترخاء والنوم،
أنت تعرف ما هو الرائع حقًا في الألعاب التي
يمكن أن تأخذك إلى مغامرات مذهلة
عندما أكون  اللعب بألعابي مثل الدمى
أستطيع أن أتخيل كل أنواع الأشياء الممتعة التي
يمكنني القيام بها في المستقبل أستطيع أن
ألعب بألعابي
مثل الدمى أستطيع أن أتخيل كل أنواع
الأشياء الممتعة التي يمكنني القيام بها
أستطيع أن
أفعلها
لا أستطيع  الذهاب إلى الفضاء الخارجي أو الغوص في أعماق
المحيط، من الجيد
الذهاب إلى رحلة سحرية، أشك في
مغادرة غرفتي،
فالألعاب ليست فقط للعب بمفردي، بل
يمكن أن تساعدني أيضًا في تكوين صداقات جديدة
عندما
أحضر ألعابي إلى المدرسة أو أذهب إلى المدرسة.
منزل صديق نلعب فيه معًا ونستمتع به ونتبادل
الأدوار ونتشارك
ونتعلم كيف نكون لطيفين مع بعضنا البعض،
من فضلك ساعدنا على ربط
صداقتيهما.
أحب الرسم والتلوين باستخدام
أقلام التلوين وكتب التلوين الخاصة بي،
لا أستطيع،
إنها طريقة مناسبة لي.  للتعبير عن نفسي، إظهار
ما أشعر به في داخلي، الأمر يشبه امتلاكي لأشياءي
الخاصة، يمكنني إنشاء صور جميلة،
صور جميلة،
تجعلني سعيدًا،
يشبه وجود معرض فني خاص بي
[موسيقى]
أحيانًا تمتلكني الألعاب أيضًا
وأحيانًا تساعدني الألعاب في ذلك  أحلم بما أريد
أن أكون عندما أكبر، عندما ألعب
أتظاهر بأنني
أستطيع أن أصبح
طبيبًا أو مدرسًا أو رجل إطفاء،
الأمر أشبه بتجربة قبعات مختلفة
وتخيل كل أنواع الأشياء الممتعة التي يمكنني
القيام بها في المستقبل،
أصدقائي الأعزاء.  عندما تلعب
بألعابك،
تذكر أنها أكثر من مجرد أشياء، فهي
أدوات سحرية يمكن أن تساعدك على
التعلم والنمو والاستمتاع
والاستمتاع بها عالم لا يصدق من
الخيال الكهربائي ينمو ويستمتع
بعالم الألعاب المذهل شكرًا لك على
الاستماع إلى ألعابي  أتمنى أن تقضي
يومًا رائعًا مع الكثير من اللعب الممتع،
وداعًا
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لكم